[Música]
Bienvenidos a reporteros el magazín de
los grandes reportajes de la redacción
de Franz 24 soy herminia Fernández
comenzamos
el 15 de agosto de 2021 los talibanes
entraron en kabul la capital afgana y
las tropas estadounidenses debieron
retirarse precipitadamente Estados
Unidos estableció rápidamente un puente
aéreo para sacar del país al personal
afgano que se encontraba amenazado por
los talibanes por haber trabajado con el
país norteamericano o con la comunidad
internacional las evacuaciones fueron
caóticas y los estadounidenses no
quisieron recibir en su territorio a los
evacuados sin hacer antes controles de
seguridad Así que recurrieron a terceros
países en total 27 acogieron a estos
afganos exiliados una de estas naciones
fue Albania donde después de un año y
medio 1100 solicitudes de asilo Siguen
sin ser procesadas veamos la historia de
nada de luz
[Música]
a 60 kilómetros de la capital albanesa
se encuentran y sus complejos hoteleros
a lo largo de la costa
[Música]
desde el verano de 2021 esta ciudad
costera ha acogido a una clientela
inesperada
[Música]
afganos que como la joven mursal huyeron
de su país cuando los talibanes tomaron
soy de Afganistán y estoy en este
complejo turístico como refugiada
no estoy aquí para divertirme Solo estoy
aquí para esperar
y como la mayoría de los afganos que
están aquí mi futuro es muy incierto
Future en agosto de 2021 las autoridades
estadounidenses apoyadas por diversas
ongs crearon un puente aéreo para
evacuar a los afganos que habían
colaborado con ellos 3000 afganos a
quienes se les prometió una nueva vida
en Estados Unidos o en Canadá
aterrizaron en Albania
lo que no se les dijo era que no les
daban la garantía de que se les otorgara
una visa cada solicitud de asilo debía
ser estudiada caso por caso
en esta ciudad de postal un año y medio
después 1100 casos Siguen sin ser
tramitados
la vida de estos afganos abandonados a
su suerte está en suspenso
Qué estás haciendo
estoy Tejiendo un suéter para tu sobrina
que ya está en Estados Unidos
desde hace casi un año bursal comparte
dos habitaciones en el hotel rafaelo con
su padre y su madre
para proteger a sus allegados que aún se
encuentran en Afganistán prefieren no
utilizar su nombre real su padre un
exfuncionario nos pidió no ser filmado
me dieron la visa hace muchos meses y el
día que me dijeron que podía irme
les dije está bien pero no quiero me
preguntaron si prefería esperar a mi
familia les dije que sí claro son mis
padres
es una verdadera locura Y algo absurdo
es una situación que ha separado a
muchas familias
trabajó con organizaciones
internacionales en kabul obtuvo su visa
para Canadá sin dificultades sus padres
no
a sus 29 años muy devota a su familia se
enfrenta a un dilema muy complicado
empezar una nueva vida en Canadá sola
denunciar a esta y quedarse en Albania
con sus padres ya mayores y enfermos
estos medicamentos me destruyeron no
queda nada de mi cuerpo
parao vamos a terminar llorando las dos
esta vez es mi turno de darte pañuelos
Es como estar en la cárcel aunque sea
una cárcel hermosa
una cárcel con vista al mar donde la
libertad se ha convertido en un
Espejismo especialmente para aquellos
que fueron directamente evacuados de
Afganistán por las organizaciones de
ayuda humanitaria estadounidenses para
ellos no hay garantía de que Estados
Unidos Les conceda una visa ni apoyo
financiero para el departamento de
estado las organizaciones que decidieron
evacuar a los afganos a Albania en 2021
deben asumir toda la responsabilidad
pero no todas lo hacen según Blender
shima gerente del Rafael
hay una organización responsable de los
afganos que no le ha pagado al hotel
desde hace varios meses y siguen estando
en deuda
son el fpg suma según nuestras cuentas
nos deben algo más de 2.8 millones de
dólares
el grupo fpg está a cargo de 321 afganos
que tuvieron que abandonar el hotel
rafaelo y que fueron realojados A
mediados de octubre en apartamentos
menos costosos
nos pusimos en contacto con la
organización la cual no nos respondió
[Música]
mirkoda fariat de 27 años es uno de los
afganos desalojados del Hotel Rafael el
fpg lo reubicó en este pequeño
apartamento donde vive con su mujer y su
hijo el federal es un bufete de abogados
de Washington fundado por un ex Marino
pero para amir como para los demás
afganos que abandonaron el hotel la
situación es desesperada
desde que nos trajeron aquí no han
cumplido ninguna de las promesas que nos
hicieron
nos dieron dinero para nuestros gastos
pero no es nada
75 dólares mensuales por persona es muy
poco
por ejemplo tan solo mi hijo pequeño
necesita una lata de leche en polvo a la
semana si lo multiplicamos por 4 al mes
son casi 80 euros
en Albania desde hace más de un año amir
trabaja de vez en cuando en esta pequeña
tienda de abarrotes albanesa donde la
mayoría de los clientes también son
afganos
yo no puedo volver al hotel rafaelo
Así que trabajo aquí con chacha el
tendero y eso me ayuda mucho
[Música]
aquel día familias que como la de amir
están bajo la tutela de la fpg fueron a
recoger su ayuda económica mensual pero
una vez más en que la suma no les
alcanzará para sobrevivir en este Rincón
albanés
la tensión
los exiliados afganos no se atreven a
criticar abiertamente a una organización
de la que dependen mientras no hayan
obtenido la visa para Estados Unidos
sin embargo este hombre accede a hablar
con nosotros conservando su anonimato
arriesgamos nuestras vidas y la razón
por la que estamos aquí es porque
apoyamos la misión del gobierno
estadounidense en Afganistán
e incluso de la otan
si nos tratan así
Por qué la gente confiaría en Estados
Unidos en el futuro
no somos mendigos si nuestro país no
hubiera sido entregado a los talibanes
nunca habríamos tenido que irnos para
los afganos que viven en el hotel
rafaelo la situación es menos precaria
reciben tres comidas al día y algunos
también reciben subsidios mensuales
incluso encontró trabajo en el hotel
todas las tardes Les enseña inglés a
aquellos que están prontos a partir
y aquí
en sus clases las mujeres son las más
sobresalientes
me alegro mucho por las mujeres que
pudieron salir de Afganistán se caen
millones de mujeres que ya no tienen la
oportunidad de estudiar
y me alegro de que las mujeres que están
acá tengan acceso a la educación que se
merecen
ninguno de estas mujeres se imaginó
vivir en Albania algún día un país que
algunas ni siquiera sabían que existía
hasta que llegaron pero para estas
jóvenes futbolistas de la selección
nacional femenina abandonar el
Afganistán de los talibanes era cuestión
de supervivencia
y espera poder sacar del país a las
jugadoras que no han logrado salir
Envía un vídeo a una de sus compañeras
de equipo que ahora está escondida en
Afganistán
Hola Mira aquí es muy bonito
estamos con las chicas y podemos
entrenar
pensamos en ti y nos gustaría que
estuvieras aquí con nosotras
para las chicas que se quedaron es muy
duro porque la situación allá Es
horrible
las jóvenes no pueden ir a la escuela no
pueden hacer deportes se quedan en casa
y no en ningún futuro para ellas
incluso dicen no sé si estaré viva
mañana
vidas destruidas en Afganistán y el
dolor del exilio para las refugiadas
afganas en Albania arrancadas de sus
familias
que sólo tiene 17 años
Estamos aquí pero nuestras familias
están lejos y las extrañamos muchísimo
algunos lograron venir con sus
familiares nosotras no Y para todas
nosotras es duro somos demasiado jóvenes
para estar separadas de nuestras
familias que están en situaciones
difíciles mi mamá está muy enferma y me
hace mucha falta cada vez que me llaman
te hice colgar se pone triste
y me pregunta si podremos reencontrarnos
algún día y tener una vida normal como
todo el mundo
me pregunta hija mía te volveré a ver
algún día
[Música]
probablemente pasará otro invierno en
Albania donde nacerá su segundo hijo
dentro de una semanas
[Música]
mursal por fin recibió el tan esperado
correo Canadá acaba de otorgarles la
visa a sus padres la familia pronto
empezará una nueva vida en este país
mursal nos cuenta sus esperanzas por
teléfono
cuando leí el correo Me sentí feliz pero
también vacía
Espero que esto no sea el comienzo de
una nueva prisión
Espero encontrar un lugar al que podamos
Llamar hogar
[Música]
[Aplausos]
al igual que todos los refugiados
afganos en Albania sueñan con una vida
mejor y con poder salir de la
incertidumbre lejos del caos de
Afganistán
[Música]
hasta aquí reporteros de la semana
recuerde que para ver esta y las
emisiones anteriores puede visitar
nuestro sitio web France 24.com hasta la
próxima
[Música]